bonjour messieurs mesdames eux donc je
m'appelle dont catherine faire repérer
donc je suis agricultrice quand même ma
voisine me le vole à 10 ce produit du
lait à comté dans le doubs nous avons la
chance d'avoir une filière pour
l'instant qui va très bien j'en parlerai
tout à l'heure on va donc aujourd'hui je
suis installé depuis 2000 dans le monde
agricole avant j'étais dans la
restauration et dans le commerce donc
deux milieux complètement différente
je suis reparti à 1 en formation très
important je n'arrive pas comme ça sur
un cheveu dans une forme dans une anse
dans une entreprise
donc je débute aujourd'hui le monde
agricole souffre il ya un mal être
c'est vrai qu'on entend beaucoup de
choses le lait n'est pas payé on n'est
pas reconnu
on nous prend pour des moins que rien
donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on a une
profession qui a observé on est une
profession qui est regardée dès qu'on
fait quoi que ce soit on est mal vu on
sonne l'alertent aujourd'hui
depuis un an les prix ce sont de cesse
de chuter de 400 euros tonne de lait
produit en janvier 2015
nous en sommes aujourd'hui à moins de
300 tonnes de lait pour janvier 2016
sachez que le coût de production n'est
d'une tonne de lait s'élève en moyenne à
3 140 tonnes ce prix entendons nous
permet tout juste de couvrir les charges
ils n'auraient mer et une hummer pas le
travail des producteurs
je pense pas que nous aujourd'hui dans
cette salle vous aimeriez aller
travailler pour le plaisir de travailler
pas gagner votre vie
je pense qu'on n'est pas beaucoup donc
il faut qu'on se réveille
j'avais fait toute une liste mais ma
collègue a bien dit il tout ce que je
voulais relever sur la productivité sur
les manque de transparence des acteurs
de la filière laitière les
industriels coopératives et
distributeurs qui souvent valorise très
bien leurs produits mais index le prix
payé au producteur sur les cours de
mondial
pour preuve deux pour preuve le prix
payé par les consommateurs n'a pas chuté
une volonté des pays du nord de l'europe
de développer la production laitière
avec des aides importantes à la
modernisation des outils et une
législation plus souple sur la question
environnementale
la conséquence directe de cette chute du
prix est l'arrêt des productions
laitière par les exploitants qui ne
peuvent plus continuer et à s'endetter
ils préfèrent aujourd'hui vendre leur
exploitation qu'il tenait à leurs
parents grands parents plutôt que de
travailler pour perdre de l'argent au
delà de pardon au delà de la reine ce
sont des dettes remboursées des projets
de vie à reconstruire et parcours
répercussions des entreprises qui ne
seront pas payés des filières entières
remise en cause et une perte du
dynamisme de nos campagnes
si vous me le permettez je souhaiterais
pouvoir apporter une réflexion en lien
avec la filière comté dans laquelle mon
nom de mon exploitation et mon mari et
moi même sommes acteurs dans cette
filière les producteurs bénéficient d'un
prix requis rémunère leur travail
et si les producteurs sont payés pour le
travail qu'ils font c'est parce qu'il
existe une meilleure répartition des
marges entre les différents maillons de
la filière
cette meilleure répartition est permise
grâce à un cahier des charges
contraignant un produit de qualité qui
satisfait les exigences du consommateur
oui mais on subit quand même des preuves
des pressions en amont les fournisseurs
profite intrants plus cher aliments du
bétail engrais paille en aval
aujourd'hui notre compte et reconnu être
s est très enviée du coup le produit
comté et du plus en plus copié compter
russe coeur de savoie et cetera la
profession veille à cela mais cela prend
quand même des parts de marché rien
n'est jamais acquis
en france on produit bien beau bon
respect du travail des paysans des
animaux de la robine de l'environnement
oui mais c'est plus possible il va
falloir faire des choix
l'agriculture française première de
l'union européenne oui mais pour combien
encore avec quelle dignité
merci